[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin einen schönen guten Abend
ihnen allen Katja es gibt eine
interessante Idee aus der zweiten
Fußball-Bundesliga eine die Schule
machen könnte schönen guten Abend dann
schauen wir jetzt gemeinsam auf die
Themen an diesem Mittwoch
Filetstück geht in die USA der Verkauf
von viessmanns wärmepumpengeschäft sorgt
für Diskussionen
[Musik]
massiv überfordert Bundesländer beraten
über den Zuzug von immer mehr
Flüchtlingen
und freier Eintritt für alle Fortuna
Düsseldorf sorgt für eine echte
Sensation im Profifußball
[Musik]
zehntausende Hauseigentümer mit älteren
Öl und Gasheizungen überlegen ob sie auf
Wärmepumpen umsteigen sollen vor allem
wegen des geplanten ampelgesetzes zum
Heizungstausch in dieser Phase die
Nachricht dass der deutsche
Heizungsbauer Viessmann seinen
wärmepumpengeschäft für 12 Milliarden
Euro an einen US-Unternehmen verkauft
Claudia Weiler hat erst einmal die
Fakten
es ist eine Zeitenwende für Viessmann
das Familienunternehmen verkauft sein
Kerngeschäft Heizung und Klimatechnik
machen 85% des Umsatzes aus und der
wächst allein im letzten Jahr plus 19
Prozent auf 4 Milliarden Euro
haupttreiber der Wachstumsmarkt
Wärmepumpe politisch gewollt und von der
Regierung gefördert bis 2030 soll die
Zahl der Anlagen auf 6 Millionen steigen
in Deutschland ist Viessmann neben Bosch
Buderus und Vaillant einer der größten
Hersteller das Problem auf den Markt
drängt internationale Konkurrenz vor
allem aus Asien mit großer Erfahrung und
geringeren Kosten gemeinsam mit carrier
will fissmann weiter im wachsenden Markt
mitmischen die Familie Viessmann soll
übrigens größter Einzelaktionär im
US-Unternehmen werden die Heizungsbauer
aus Allendorf wollen auch in Zukunft
mitreden wie sie aussehen soll die
zeitenwände bei Viessmann
und dieser
wärmepumpen-how können verloren gehen
mehr zur Situation und dazu wie Experten
die Marktlage einschätzen von Peter
Wagner
zigtausende klassische Viessmann
Heizungen laufen in deutschen Kellern
und Haushalten seit neuestem werden auch
jede Menge Wärmepumpen eingebaut Kunden
schätzen die Qualität made in Nordhessen
doch jetzt wird Viessmann amerikanisch
der US-Konzern Carrier global kauft das
wärmegeschäft der Nordhessen für 12
Milliarden Euro es stehen jetzt sehr
große Wettbewerbe an den Startlöchern
aus Asien aus Japan aus China aus
Südkorea und Viessmann alleine ist
wahrscheinlich zu klein für diesen
Wettbewerb man braucht einen starken
Partner an der Seite der viel Kapital
auch in das Unternehmen reingibt
Wärmepumpen boomen wegen der
Energiewende die Technik dieser Heizung
funktioniert im Prinzip wie eine
umgekehrte Klimaanlage und davon bauen
die großen asiatischen und
amerikanischen Konzerne seit langem
Millionen pro Jahr deshalb drängen sie
mit ihren Kapazitäten ihren Kapital und
Know-how in den europäischen Markt
Firmenchef Maxx Viessmann erklärte heute
die Entscheidung zum Verkauf der
heizungssparte in der Familie nicht
leicht gefallen es ging um Größe um
Wachstum und Wettbewerbsfähigkeit in den
globalen Märkten allein habe Viessmann
den Weg in die Zukunft nicht bewältigen
können
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck sieht in dem
Geschäft eine gute Botschaft für die
Verbraucher die Beteiligung von Carrier
global bei Viessmann wird auch dazu
führen dass die Wärmepumpen des Hauses
Viessmann günstiger werden denn der
ganze Sinn der Operation ist ja mehr zu
produzieren Viessmann und Carrier haben
im Zuge des verkaufsbetriebsbedingte
Kündigungen für drei Jahre
ausgeschlossen die Gewerkschaft macht
sich dennoch sorgen die Ängste die wir
damit haben die sind nicht konkret
Viessmann bezogen aber grundsätzlich ist
es so dass wir immer mit
nordamerikanischen Unternehmen in der
Mitbestimmung in den letzten Jahrzehnten
nicht die allerbesten Erfahrungen
gemacht haben Fachleute halten den
Schritt Viessmann für folgerichtig ob es
der Beginn eines neuen Ausverkaufs in
einer wichtigen Zukunftsbranche war das
wird sich erst zeigen
ja der wärmepumpendiel und die Folgen
unser Thema bei ZDF heute live gleich um
19 Uhr geht es los auf unseren Social
Media Kanälen und über die ZDF heute App
nach der corona-zeit und trotz der
Energiekrise sieht die Bundesregierung
die deutsche Wirtschaft auf dem Weg der
Erholung in seiner frühjahrsprojektion
rechnet Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck für
dieses Jahr mit einem leichten Wachstum
von 0,4% deutlich mehr als zu Beginn des
Winters die Inflation soll zurückgehen
mit
5,9% würde sie aber weiter auf einem
hohen Niveau bleiben
für Bahnreisende bleibt es eine
schwierige Zeit wieder drohen
Warnstreiks die dritte Tarifrunde
zwischen Bahn Management und der
Gewerkschaft EVG wurde ohne Ergebnis
beendet die EVG bezeichnete das neue
Angebot der Bahn als nicht verhandelbar
die nächsten Verhandlungen sind für Ende
Mai geplant neue Warnstreiks gelten als
sehr wahrscheinlich
für rund 21 Millionen Rentner gibt es ab
1 Juli mehr Geld die Bundesregierung hat
die geplante Rentenerhöhung beschlossen
die Bezüge im Westen steigen dann um
4,39%, die im Osten um
5,86% damit wird gleichzeitig die
Angleichung der Rentenwerte im Osten an
Westniveau erreicht
der Bundestag hat die vorerst
abgeschlossene bundeswehr-mission zur
Evakuierung deutscher Staatsangehöriger
aus dem Sudan fast einstimmig gebilligt
nur einige Abgeordnete der Linken
enthielten sich die Luftwaffe hatte bei
ihrem Rettungseinsatz in den vergangenen
Tagen mehrere hundert Menschen in
Sicherheit gebracht Deutsche die sich
noch im Sudan befinden können aber noch
auf Ausreise hoffen mehr dazu und zur
Situation im Sudan jetzt von Lena
sünderbruch
mehr als 700 Menschen hat die Bundeswehr
aus dem Sudan ausgeflogen zunächst nach
Jordanien dann weiter nach Deutschland
die evakuierungsflüge anderer Nationen
gehen weiter deutsche die noch im Sudan
sind sollen in den nächsten Tagen von
internationalen Partnern mitgenommen
werden in der Nacht hat der
UN-Sicherheitsrat die Angriffe beider
Konfliktparteien im Sudan verurteilt es
habe Attacken auf dicht besiedelte
Gebiete gegeben keine Rücksicht auf
Zivilisten und Krankenhäuser es gibt
noch keine Anzeichen dafür dass eine der
beiden Seiten bereit ist ernsthaft zu
verhandeln was darauf hindeutet dass
beide glauben dass ein militärischer
Sieg über den anderen möglich ist das
ist eine Fehleinschätzung
obwohl der Waffenstillstand bis morgen
und Mitternacht verlängert wurde gibt es
immer wieder Gefechte aus der Hauptstadt
cartoon werden Luftangriffe und
Explosionen gemeldet
das ist der dritte Waffenstillstand aber
die Leute glauben nicht mehr daran
wir haben die Nase voll wir können
unsere Häuser nicht verlassen auch wenn
uns etwas anderes gesagt wird
ein Hilferuf kommt von der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation mitten in
der Hauptstadt sei ein medizinlabor
besetzt worden dort werde an Polio
Masern und Cholera geforscht so kommt
nun noch ein großes biologisches Risiko
hinzu zu Versorgungsproblemen bei Strom
und Wasser Engpässen bei Lebensmitteln
und Medikamenten viele Einwohner wollen
nur noch fliehen
die Situation im Sudan auch Thema bei
der UNO wo Russland ja derzeit den
Vorsitz in Sicherheitsrat hat Russlands
Außenminister lavrov wurde dort auf
einer Pressekonferenz zu möglichen
Einsetzen der russischen Söldnertruppe
Wagner im Sudan befragt Johannes Hano in
New York und das mit sehr tiefblickenden
Antworten
ja sehr genau hat gesagt das Wagner die
Wagner soldnertruppe eine private
Einheit sei die ganz legal international
ein Service anbieten würde und dass
dieser Service von Ländern wie Mali der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik aber auch
dem Sudan angenommen worden sei wie
dieser Service aussieht hat er nicht
gesagt aber wir wissen von einer ganzen
Palette die Wagner anbietet das geht von
politischer das Informationskampagnen
und destabilisationskampagnen bis zur
Entsendung von bewaffneten Einheiten und
Wagner ist dafür bekannt dass man
besonders brutal und rücksichtslos dann
auch gegen die Zivilbevölkerung vorgeht
und das führt dazu so sind hier viele
Beobachter sich einigermaßen einig dass
ein größeres politisches
geostrategisches Ziel Russlands damit
auch verfolgt wird nämlich den
fluchtdruck auf die europäischen
Außengrenzen zu erhöhen um Europa weiter
zu destabilisieren danke für die
Einordnung nach New York Johannes Hano
die Zahl geflüchteter die über das
Mittelmeer und Europa zu uns kommen die
steigt stark an seit Monaten schlagen
Kommunen und Bundesländer Alarm wie man
geflüchtete besser integriert darüber
beraten heute und morgen die
Integrationsminister der Länder ein
Blick jetzt auf die Zahlen schon Anfang
2022 gab es mehr Asylbewerber als in den
Jahren zuvor ab Sommer stieg die Zahl
dann deutlich
Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der Ukraine die
kommen zusätzlich dazu wie weit die
Kommunen in dieser Situation vom Ziel
der Integration entfernt sind das zeigt
jetzt der Bericht von Susanna Santina
diese containerwohnungen für 1,3
Millionen Euro hessischen Erlensee
werden ab morgen von 160 syrischen und
afghanischen geflüchteten gewohnt in
Main-Kinzig-Kreis ist es mittlerweile
die 15 Gemeinschaftsunterkunft das sei
notwendig sagt der Landrat letzten
Dezember wurden täglich 160 Flüchtlinge
zugewiesen
es ist eine riesenkraftanstrengung immer
ein kindskreis hat etwas über 420.000
Einwohnerinnen und Einwohner und wir
haben im vergangenen Jahr ungefähr
9.200 Menschen als geflüchtete als
Asylsuchende hier bei uns in den 29
Städten und Gemeinden untergebracht und
einfach auch versorgt wirklich glücklich
ist man über die Unterkünfte im
Gewerbegebiet von Erlensee nicht es sei
aus der Not geboren eigentlich um ihn zu
integrieren müsste man Menschen in
Wohnraum unterbringen und zwar in
eigenen Wohnraum mit Nachbarn mit einer
Community drumherum mit Vereinsleben
also genau das Gegenteil von dem was wir
hier eigentlich tun es kamen deutlich
mehr als in der flüchtlingskrise 2015/16
sagen viele Kommunen und schlagen seit
Monaten Alarm diese Zelte in Bensheim
waren als provisorische Unterkunft
gedacht geflüchtete aus Syrien der
Türkei und Afghanistan leben hier seit
Monaten
und ein ganzer Teil davon kommt ohne
Bleibeperspektive und bleibt trotzdem da
und nimmt uns damit Ressourcen und um
die Menschen zu kümmern um tatsächlich
Bleibeperspektive haben denn die sollten
integriert werden doch das ist auch im
Kreis Bergstraße angesichts von rund
4.000 geflüchteten allein im letzten
Jahr kaum möglich der Frust bei vielen
ist groß
wenn ihr keinen Platz habt warum habt
ihr uns dann aufgenommen warum
lasst uns raus
ich bin schon seit zwei Monaten hier
aber viele schon seit sechs bis acht
Monaten das ist ein großes Problem
monatelang in solchen Unterkünften eine
Integration ist bei vielen Kommunen kaum
zu denken vorrangig geht es darum
Wohnraum zu schaffen allein das ist eine
große Herausforderung
das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz hat
drei Rechte Vereinigungen als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch eingestuft dabei
handelt es sich um die afd-jugend
Organisation junge alternative das
sogenannte Institut für Staatspolitik
und den Verein ein Prozent bestimmten
keine Zweifel mehr dass diese drei
Organisationen verfassungsfeindliche
Bestrebungen verfolgten
ein Kernproblem der Bundeswehr ist die
Ausrüstung zu teuer zu wenig zu spät der
Truppe fehlt es an vielem vor allem am
Tempo für die Beschaffung und das will
Minister Pistorius jetzt mit neuen
Regeln ändern etwa statt auf
zeitraubende Spezialanfertigung zu
warten solle die Bundeswehr künftig
öfter auf Rüstungsgüter zurückgreifen
die schon am Markt verfügbar sein Ihnen
die Kampfschwimmer warten noch immer auf
neue Schlauchboote die Anforderungen zu
umfangreich die Beschaffung wurde
abgebrochen ein Transportflieger der zu
teuer wird und zu spät kommt ein Panzer
der im Feld Probleme bereitet weil er zu
viele Dinge können sollen damit soll nun
Schluss sein so will es der neue
Verteidigungsminister
Priorität 1 hat ab sofort bei allen
Beschaffung der Faktor Zeit dem muss
sich alles unterordnen Fesseln die wir
selber uns angelegt haben werden wir
abwerfen Pistorius will mehr Tempo in
die Beschaffung bringen Vorstellung des
Reform Erlasses heute im
Verteidigungsausschuss so soll es
künftig keine Sonderanfertigung mehr
geben weniger komplizierte interne
Vorschriften und mehr Mitsprache der
Teilstreitkräfte Boris pistorisches
Führungsqualität zeichnet sich dadurch
aus dass er besonders
unorthodoxe geniale Ideen hat sondern
dass er das Offensichtliche umsetzt und
dass ich auch in dieser Weisung
allerdings kann ich nur sagen dass seine
vorgängerung schon ein Gesetz unter
anderem auf dem Weg gebracht hat das
sogenannte
beschaffungsbeschleunigungsgesetz was
dabei rauskam war das sich nichts
beschleunigt hat jahrelang ging
Innenministerium und Beschaffungsamt
Perfektion und absolute Rechtssicherheit
vor Schnelligkeit ein Mentalitätswandel
tut Not der Erlass des Ministers kann
nur Anfang sein
das ist eine wesentliche Weichenstellung
für eine Kulturveränderung in der
Organisation das umzusetzen und
durchzudrücken ist natürlich eine
weitere Führungsaufgabe für Minister
gehen Sie mutig an die Neuerung dran
appelliert Pistorius heute an die
Mitarbeiter in Truppe und Ministerium er
weiß er braucht ihre Bereitschaft zur
Veränderung
China verstärkt seine diplomatischen
Aktivitäten rund um den Ukraine Krieg
Präsident schied telefonierte zum ersten
Mal mit dem ukrainischen Präsidenten
selensky dieser sprach von einem langen
und sinnvollen Telefonat es wäre aber
keinen Frieden auf Basis von
Gebietsverlusten geben peking will jetzt
einen Sondergesandten in die Region
schicken der mit allen Seiten das
Gespräch suchen soll
zu einer Nachricht aus dem Iran die
aufhorchen lässt denn dort hat das
Oberste Gericht das Todesurteil gegen
den Deutsch Iraner jumpshit charmant
bestätigt dem 68-Jährigen wird unter
anderem vorgeworfen an einem Anschlag
auf eine Moschee beteiligt gewesen zu
sein und mit ausländischen
Geheimdiensten kooperiert zu haben
Außenministerin bärbock forderte den
Iran auf dieses Zitat willkürliche
Urteil unverzüglich rückgängig zu machen
wir fragen jetzt Glück Wahl Port der
regelmäßig aus dem Iran berichtet lügt
die Bundesregierung übt scharfe Kritik
am Todesurteil was kann Berlin jetzt
eigentlich noch ausrichten
das muss man jetzt abwarten aber
vermutlich doch weniger als noch vor
Jahren denn das gesamte geostrategische
Gleichgewicht hat sich verändert und die
Einflussmöglichkeiten die Europa
generell und Deutschland dem besonderen
noch auf Teheran hat sind ganz sicher
geringer als noch vor Jahren die
iranische Justiz hat heute abend klar
gemacht dass sie dieses Urteil
umzusetzen gedenkt es wurde auch
angewiesen bereits die Bedingungen zu
schaffen für die Vorbereitung der
Vollstreckung des Urteils das heißt
konkret das Leben von Herrn macht hängt
wirklich am seinen Faden ist akut
bedroht der deutsche Botschafter wurde
von einer Dienstreise zurückfordern man
will jetzt ausloten welchen
diplomatischen Druck man auch aufbauen
kann aber die Tatsache dass Iran sich
nicht mehr international isoliert fühlt
dass es mit China und Russland neuerding
starke Partner hat lässt mich da eher
skeptisch sein also die Möglichkeiten
Druck auszuüben auf Teheran sind
begrenzt danke lucky walport
jetzt schauen wir nach Israel dort
feiert man in diesen Tagen ein ganz
besonderes Jubiläum vor 75 Jahren wurde
der Staat gegründet
1948 da ruft Gründervater David Ben
Gurion die Unabhängigkeit aus für
Millionen Juden wird der Traum eines
eigenen Staates war am gleichen Tag
greifen die arabischen Nachbarn an
hunderttausende Palästinenser müssen
infolge des Krieges fliehen oder werden
vertrieben ein Konflikt der bis heute
fehlt und auch in den politisch steht
Israel vor großen Herausforderungen über
das Jubiläum Michael Beverungen
75 Jahre Israel ein besonderer
Geburtstag in vielerlei Hinsicht die
Israelis scheinen ihn trotzdem so wie
jedes Jahr zu feiern entspannt am Strand
mit einer großen Flugshow dabei übrigens
erstmals auch ein deutscher Kampfjet der
Streit um die Justizreform die Tiefe
Spaltung der Nation heute soll alles
einen Tag ruhen
die Wahrheit ist die Lage ist sehr
kompliziert aber ich bin stolz auf
Israel auf das was sie erreicht haben
auf den Aufbau des Landes es gibt
Probleme aber wir werden sie lösen heute
sollten wir uns nicht darauf
konzentrieren wir haben das ganze Jahr
dafür nicht am Feiertag doch die Tiefe
Staatskrise macht nur eine kurze Pause
ausgerechnet zum 75 Geburtstag steckt
Israel in der schwersten
innenpolitischen Krise seit seiner
Gründung es geht um nicht weniger als
den Erhalt der Gewaltenteilung um den
Erhalt der Demokratie an sich und die
große Frage ist wie die Tiefe Spaltung
der Nation überwunden werden soll
dass die Gewaltenteilung so leicht
auszuhebeln sein würde hatten die
Gründer und bengorion in der Euphorie
1948 wohl übersehen Sicherungen wie eine
zweite Kammer oder eine geschriebene
Verfassung besitzt Israel nicht die
Demonstrationen gegen die Justizreform
gingen auch zu Beginn der feiern gestern
weiter vielleicht etwas heiterer als
sonst
der Sommer in Europa der hat noch gar
nicht angefangen da purzeln in Spanien
schon die ersten Hitze Rekorde im Süden
des Landes könnten es in den nächsten
Tagen bis zu 40 Grad werden schon jetzt
liegen die Werte an vielen Orten
zwischen 5 und 10 Grad über dem
jahreszeitlichen Durchschnitt Grund ist
eine Hitzewelle aus Nordafrika an sich
nicht ungewöhnlich aber die Masse an
heißer Trockner Luft bricht viel zu früh
im Jahr über die iberische Halbinsel
herein
so jetzt zum Sport und einer Sache die
ist Katja so eigentlich noch dich gab ja
immer neue Wege im Fußball zweitliges
fortuna Düsseldorf hat sich was
interessantes überlegt ein Pilotprojekt
im Sinne der Fans die dürfen in der
kommenden Saison ins Stadion und
brauchen zumindest bei einigen Spielen
keinen Eintritt zahlen
Fortuna für alle heißt die neue
strategische Ausrichtung der freie
Eintritt soll den Zuschauern zunächst
bei mindestens drei Heimspielen in der
kommenden Saison angeboten werden später
bei allen Partien zu Hause auch den
Gästefans zusätzliche Sponsoren werden
die fehlenden Ticketeinnahmen abfangen
wir sind dankbar dass diese Partner in
den nächsten fünf Jahren für rund 45
Millionen Euro über 5 Jahre uns ein
sicheres wirtschaftliches Fundament
geben mit dem Geld sollen auch Nachwuchs
und Frauenfußball sowie Infrastruktur
und soziale Projekte unterstützt werden
wir haben ganz klares Ziel wir wollen
die Fortuna stärker aufstellen wir
wollen Vorteile für die Stadt Düsseldorf
wir haben die Vorteile für unsere Fans
herausarbeiten ein mutiges Projekt das
schon jetzt für viel Aufsehen gesorgt
hat
ja viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommt gerade
auch der FC Bayern München inklusive
Trainer Thomas Tuchel der Rekordmeister
steckt in einer handfesten Krise nach
dem Aus im DFB-Pokal der Champions
League und nach der verdienten 1:3
Niederlage am Samstag gegen Mainz
außergewöhnlich dieser Besuch der
mächtige Ehrenpräsident Uli Hoeneß und
Trainer Thomas Tuchel 15 Minuten
engagiertes Gespräch danach das erste
Training nach drei Tagen der Besinnung
runterkommen Abkühlen auf die eigenen
Stärken besinnen was da in Mainz
passierte das rüttelt an den Grundfesten
des bayerischen Selbstvertrauens des mir
san mir Kritik von exponierter Stelle
Ex-Bayer Lothar Matthäus greift den
Vorstandschef an Karl hat den Laden
nicht im Griff der Trainerwechsel zu
Tuchel er sei überstürzt gekommen die
gesamte Vereinsführung bekommt ihr Fett
ab auch außerhalb der Fachkreise
habe ich eigentlich noch nie so richtig
gemocht als Torwart schon aber so als
Vorstand würde ich sagen
ihr soll irgendwie fehl am Platz am
Sonntag gegen schließlich Hertha BSC
muss die kehrt während der Herr sonst
würde aus dem strammen Gegenwind ein
Sturm
dann kommt glaube ich auch nach Hagel
dazu wahrscheinlich danke Katja so wir
haben noch die Zahlen vom Mittwochslotto
1 3 18 25 41 49 Superzahl 7 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf lotto.zdf.de und auf
der ZDF Textseite 557
zum Wetter so viel es wird Trockner mehr
gleich von Österreich um 21:45 Uhr
beginnt es heute journal mit Christian
Sievers an dieser Stelle begrüßt sie
morgen Barbara halweg danke fürs
Interesse für Sie noch einen entspannten
Abend und auf bald
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter bei uns ist es
noch recht kühl aber es kommt mildere
Luft aus dem Südwesten zu uns ja das ist
aber kein Vergleich zu dem was in
Spanien passiert dort eine veritable
Hitzewelle 35 und teils bis 40 Grad
werden dort erwartet in den nächsten
Tagen in der Nacht gibt es in
Deutschland im Nordwesten Regen oder
auch ganz im Süden sonst dazwischen
lockerzimmer auf und auch Nebel ist mit
dabei Temperaturen gehen zurück auf -3
Grad nach Westen hin und 5 Grad z.B im
Südosten Deutschlands ja morgen dann im
Süden einzelne Schauer die dann sich
verabschieden sonst kommen neue Schauer
im Nordwesten auf dazwischen doch recht
häufig sonnige Abschnitte und harmlose
bewölkerung bei höchsten Temperaturen
bis 19 Grad im Südwesten Deutschlands
deutlich kühler nach Nordosten und vor
allem in den Küsten Temperaturen um die
zehn Grad mager die nächsten Tage
am Freitag ziemlich durchwachsen mit
neuen Schauern und Gewittern
Temperaturen 11 bis 19 Grad am Samstag
wird es allmählich Trockner vor allem
von Westen her Regen gibt es dann
Richtung Erzgebirge und im Süden
Deutschlands bei 12 bis 20 Grad und
damit ein schöner Abend